devoir deviner qu'il a prononcée dans
quel contexte attention volant elle est
derrière non vos enfants ont besoin d'un
petit coup de pouce pour la rentrée je
propose des discours d'encouragement
personnalisés loana bravo
sauf que là on bosse ici on vit que son
enfant reçoit une photo d'une
non allez on va dire la vérité parce que
je veux pas qu'on se moque et là je suis
sérieux deux minutes ce sera la partie
sera l'hôte de l'émission mais c'est
plus voilà j'espère que c'est ce même
palais vaut mieux quelqu'un va pouvoir
l'aider ou tendre la main sur la même
vidéo voilà pourquoi donc en fait est ce
que quelqu'un pour expliquer le contexte
à la maîtresse devenant alors elle s'est
installée sur une application qui
s'appelle gcg pas cité le nom parce que
là c'est une marque ou dedans vous
pouvez faire des vidéos rémunéré ou vous
souhaiter une bonne rentrée pour les
enfants des vidéos de mariage
anniversaire tout ce que vous voulez
loana fait la promo donc de ce cette
nouvelle application voilà en proposant
ses services mais malheureusement on le
voit qu'elle est pas tout seul dans sa
tête de ce qu'elle a pris enfin on voit
qu'elle n'est pas clean et xing et c'est
très très triste à les regarder ce
qu'elle a posté sur instagram notamment
pour répondre à des gens qui avaient vu
des photos d'elle pendant le shooting où
elle n'était pas nickel ni quel sens
cela sans filtre et regardez la vidéo
qu'elle a posté ces horribles pour les
loulous alors voilà vous m'avez nature
faire dire non je les sais que vous avez
vu des images de moi a pas très
facile que
ça arrive de temps en temps tu pété un
câble à 1 dans
n'importe quel monde le mien le vôtre ce
tout le temps en temps on en vient peu
de bon voila voila vous la rencontrez
votre loi l'un à côté
link phishing ça c'était pour faire
donc c'est vraiment gentil dans l'état
où vous vous pensez que tout ce que vous
soyez que je suis ben en fait vous
tromper je suis son maquillage
j'avais pas dire sans mener impasse peu
après sa passe pas sera installé voyez
la loi naturelle et puis c'est celle que
vous aimez j'espère
enfin oui
c'était le cas il ya quelques années
pourquoi
pour voilà on a assez on a laissé
évidemment là le leur cadence à dans sa
valise en intégralité bah oui faut
savoir quand même que c'est là au moins
la dixième vidéo de ce genre en un an un
an et demi mais c'est pas à nouveau lé
voilà elle se fait régulièrement
dézinguer sur les réseaux pour ce genre
de vidéos faut savoir aussi ont parlé
d'argent il ya deux secondes qu'elle a
quasiment plus rien elle a vendu
l'appartement qu'elle avait ras dans le
centre de paris près des champs-elysées
il ya quelques temps heureusement son
dernier coppens et eryl prayer un koné
qui est venu beaucoup dans tpm paix avec
qui elle a commencé d'ailleurs à faire
des shows mais des choix un peu glauque
que pas très riche voilà sur des
péniches des trucs un peu sinistre et
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui est vraiment
au bout du bout à la fois financièrement
et au niveau de sa santé et
effectivement on en parlait ce et
non-assistance à personne en danger
pourquoi on est en train de regarder ça
et on connaît l'issue
un assistant de la part du toit des
médias notamment de la barre
que je n'aime pas c'est quand on dit
c'est de la télé responsables de salons
elle n'était pas déjà très équilibré
quand elle est rentrée la terrible et
mon ami un peu plus dessus tu mets une
loupe est quelque chose mais c'est pas
la télé qui est responsable de ça c'est
le les choix qu'elle a fait l'avion mais
ce que j'aimerais demander à m et à
benoît parce que moi en revanche alors
attention je veux à personne ni avec ses
laroche joubert je vise personne mais
qu'on arrête de me dire comme je
l'entendais dix fois à tf1 ces mômes été
suivie avait un psy on en prenait soin
ces fossiles dans secret story tous les
mois jusqu'à la fin une fois que j'ai eu
la victoire aux j'ai eu une heure avec
un psy mais après c'est vrai que une
fois qu'on a fait du pastore mois après
j'ai été invité dans des fêtes
grandioses incroyable oui j'avais jamais
vu ou croisés de la drogue de ma vie
après je suis arrivé dans des grands
appartements parisiens benoît est ce que
tu peux vous raconter juste un truc
parce que tu m'as classe à ciney que tu
ne connais tu peux vite vrillé de
dambenois quotas quand il a gagné benoît
il après un succès plus de 300 mille
ballons tout comme ça des 5000 km2 900
milles et c'est ça qui est intéressant
est ton derrière et emmené dans un hôtel
pour que ça se calme tellement rêvé de
fouler il tombe dans une chambre d'hôtel
pendant qu'au même jour alors moi
pendant une semaine j'étais vraiment
sous la responsabilité de tf1 avec des
gardes du corps je n'ai pas le droit de
sortir de l'hôtel j'ai paloise ouvrir
les rideaux avec les frire la face ça a
duré pendant une semaine genre
appartenait il m'emmenait un peu comme
un produit télévisuel à droite la gauche
est au bout d'une semaine et m'ont dit
où est ce que tu veux qu'on te ramène et
moi je dis bah je sais pas jj barrea
mais moi chez ma mère et mon descendu
donc jusqu'à chez ma mère avec des
photographes suivez j'arrive devant chez
ma mère il ya des paparazzi qui sont
devant chez ma mère de mon petit village
en bourgogne c'est la totale et après
leur grosse voiture de production repart
et moi j'ai tout cela avec elle à benoît
m10 est passé quasiment un acte des gens
une semaine dans un hôtel à paris je
n'avais pas droit de sortir les gens
venaient dans la chambre d'hôtel pouvait
faire un jour un garde du corps pour
qu'il comptera c'est fini tf1 tidiane
dème hold up à gardes du corps te dépose
quelque part tout le monde se barre mais
dans un truc et c'est fini je ferai tout
ce que je croyais pas ce qu elle avait
tu l'as vécu c'est zahia oui moi ce soir
j'ai vécu quelque chose de très
similaires alors que j'avais même pas
gagné cette saison là mais c'est vrai
qu'il est beaucoup d'engouement ça ait
fait un peu le buzz et tout donc ils
m'ont mis aussi à disposition gardes du
corps chauffeur moi j'ai pas vécu ce
truc que de la même manière que benoît
l'a déjà dit les a gardées le garde du
corps et les chauffeurs moi je les ai
plus drôle non mais vous avez chanté
l'un à l'autre vous auriez pu briller
il ya une espèce de pression les médias
les intêrets les demandes d'interview
mais j'ai senti quand même par un
certain cadre je peux pas dire qu'ils
m'ont jetée comme ça dans la nature
c'est pas vrai je peux comprendre qu'on
puisse péter un câble parce que du jour
au lendemain quand c'est fini nous
disent bas vous rentrez j'ai tu voyais
aussi pendant là bas ou à deux et si
j'en ai vu un à l'entrée voilà entrés
dans la maison mais après il n'y a pas
eu de suite tout cas battu vie après y'a
plus de celui dans le loft ce qu'ont
vécu hier m benoît c'est quand même dix
ans après le premier loft donc
évidemment il ya des choses qui sont
faites à l'époque loi n'a pas été lâché
dans la nature à elle ensuite de faire
tout ce qu'elle veut en matière de
presse people mais elle elle n'a pas été
contrôlé ni cadrés et vous voyez ce
qu'on voit ce que ça donne
ça tape pas tous en même temps ces
dépôts et si oui il ya un truc qui a un
peu injuste c'est que à l'époque comment
quand j'avais préparé les 20 ans du loft
j'avais beaucoup discuté avec steevy et
il m'avait dit lui qu'ils avaient tous
essayé de faire un pas vers l qu'ils
avaient tous ses saints musulmans la
main de l'accueillir chez eux et c est
qu elle n'avait pas voulu elle n'en
voulait pas donc il n'y a pas eu non
plus une non assistance à personne en
danger ils ont quand même
installé chez elle si lui dans sa
famille c'est tout public un vrai cadre
c'est tout à fait vrai là j'ai
alors à lorient ben moi j'aime bien ton
avis laurent juste une chose parce que
là on parle 10 à 20 ans du suivi qui a
eu mais moi je parle je réponds à is
able prouesses de l'aspect médiatique
c'est à dire que le problème de ces
vidéos là c'est que si vous avez sur
tous les sites people que tout le monde
regarde pure people gala closer et c'est
le lendemain de ces vidéos de ces vidéos
là elle est sur tous les sites tout à
fait et il ce fluide mais quand d'une
certaine façon et nous de nous là c'est
bien parce qu'on a un débat justement
sur est-ce qu'il faut pas intervenir
faire quelque chose mais ces sites là ne
le font pas ils se reprennent tous les
uns les autres et elles et les addicts à
ça c'est ce que disaient aussi steevy
elle est addict au fait d'être prises
quelle que soit la façon centrale sont
après moi il a envie de moi
parce qu'on passe et l'imaginaire qui
m'a dit qui m'a dit on ne peut pas
aider quelqu'un qui refuse de l'aide il
s'abandonne ceux qui s'abandonnent
abandonne ce jeu brandon ces jolies way
you lie part ii
était en contact avec me dis alors moi
j'ai des nouvelles de temps en temps et
à l'époque ce n'est pas vrai qu'on peux
pas l'aider on est tous là en train de
regarder son entourage les médias
profitent d'air son entourage a profité
d'elle ces mecs l'on abusé de mon pris
tout son argent à l'époque vous lui
avait tendu la main l'adieu prises avec
vous en plateau c'est pas vrai on peux
pas l'aider c'est juste comme d'habitude
les êtres humains regarde les chaunois
yen s'est passé si on est honnête on à
moi je veux dire on a tout tenté nous on
a produit trois émissions avec elle
était chroniqueuse chez moi sur le mag
elle est une émission de relooking je
pense que l'excès aussi a fait des
émissions avec même financièrement à la
fée les anges et franchement nrj 12 les
amis dans les anges pour l'aider parce
que je vous raconte pas que ça a été
très galère les anges de raconter la
saison avec quelques aises voilà il ya
un moment c'est benoît vachon je vais
revenir sur un show à une chose qui
choque tous et les danses ou jour il ya
toujours son histoire de dents qui
m'arrêtent où est le problème c'est que
loana j'ai l'impression qu'elle détruit
tout ce qu'on lui propose comme si
c'était de l'autodestruction en
permanence et benoît groulx temps ça
peut nous raconter ses regrets pour les
3g le fin mot de l'histoire c'est à dire
que à dubaï est une société qui lui a
proposé de lui payer ses dents pour
avoir des nouvelles dans parce qu'elle
avait les dents très abîmés par la vie
par les excès et donc à la fait un
premier voyage à dubaï et lui ont
extrait les dents ils y ont fait un
provisoire celui qu'elle porte de perm
en main provisoire ça se met que
quelques mois quelques semaines f en
attendant de faire le moulage définit la
matelote étant alors c'est à dire
qu'elle est rentrée en france tant que
la prothèse dentaire se fasse sur dubaï
et quand ils l'ont rappelé pour qu'elle
revienne dépôt me reposer le définitive
elle n'a jamais repris l'avion parce
qu'elle perd parti dans ses travers et
du coup elle a gardé le provisoire c'est
pour ça qu'il va vite et qui bouge
ça devait être gratuit on lui a proposé
qu'elle a pas fait l a pas terminé de
très bien est ce que ce sont 2 on sent
quand même qu'un appel au secours de la
part de cette jeune femme
ah bon et quand elle se montre comme ça
quand elle dit voilà
je dirais qu elle est complètement
azimuté en tout cas cela veut dire suite
le compteur n'est pas cette image là
nous c'était pas pour se moquer ou pour
rire c'est que alors je n'ai pas de
solution non plus jeune âge ou combo de
faire quelque chose mais je sais rien
mais j'étais juste que ça va mal finir
voilà c'est ça non mais je ne souhaite
pas de cerveau la notoriété le fric
c'est pas tes j'allais le dire pardon
banon mais bon je ne
roule cool à tort mis
nombre de conneries moitié de son sang
du christ
gérant ce que j'avais à dire ouais y'a
pas ça me fait me fier de parler d'elles
on voit pas ce que je trouve qu'on l'ait
pas à a commenté ses frasques et et sa
déchéance quoi oui sauf qu'elle n'a pas
changé donc si on va là dessus c'est la
production qui lorsqu'elle a casté
agnostique avait des gros 5 était
fragile c'est elle qu'il fallait s'en
prendre et pas elle parce qu'elle n'a
pas changé loi non